[Music]
last night I was standing there looking
at a monitor on one camera was Linda
Hamilton and on another camera was
shorts Nagar my thought holy [ __ ] I'm
making a Terminator movie then let's
recapture that tone
it's r-rated it's grim it's gritty it's
fast its intense look hard and play hard
and this is what this video is all about
in musti's fresh vision and like what he
did in Bedford his action is here it's
just a fast white-knuckle ride you
better watch your ass I hunt terminators
metal [ __ ]
but follows tonally in the footsteps so
t1 and t2 that adrenaline rush feeling
that sense of terror
the action is 10 times bigger it's like
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
this film is relentless it just does not
stop
just [ __ ] in self
I'll do it when we win by keeping you
alive
terminator dark state as the direct
sequel to Terminator to pick up the
characters that we knew from Terminator
2 and we carry them forward we get to
continue the story with Jim backed and
the writing in the producing chair
he knows the material nobody else I
think for fans of the franchise the
biggest thing is that Linda's return
people love this character people love
Sarah
big back is wonderful saris a force to
be reckoned with
and I was ready to explore that I'm
delighted to work again with the
Hamilton directed Cameron Tamila live
adore the new cast there's new film is
recaptured that tall and of those first
two films it's gritty
it's fast it's intense
and it's just a white-knuckle ride
[Music]
[Music]
two days ago I had this nice simple life
I know it's a nightmare
[Music]
I'm stopped
[Music]
who are you my name is Sarah Connor and
the Percy one like you before almost
human
I am human
well you care what happens to her
because I was her
now do we win we win by keeping you
alive
I'm going hunting
[Music]
[Music]